pick a door all right there
no that's my door picking out the door
what's wrong with you you know what you
were right this is your job what's the
matter you got a lot of bad guys behind
that door
[Music]
[Applause]
access granted access denied access
denied access denied through cobs and
Turkish or we've got unfinished business
sure sister took something from me a
virus could wipe out half the population
and I want it back
gonna tell me just what we're dealing
with here it's my sister family is when
it's the fate of the world it becomes my
business his whole thing sounds really
dodgy look off new system listen I'll
handle it the only way we survive this
working together like a team let's do
this buckle up that way oh you have no
idea how long I've been waiting to do
that started
I see we can get it sick so you guys are
being hunted by an army of mercenaries
led by a genetically enhanced soldier
look at me I brought Superman three
crazy
yeah he really is black Superman you
need to get off the grid we're home my
babies come home I'm sorry to bring
trouble here mama
but I need my brothers this family is
going to war we're gonna need cars and
guns
mama where's all our guns
I can't read up on very noble mrs. Hobbs
no in serious trouble
yes understatement let's get old-school
come on
tell me this is not happening
you